[Music]
hi everybody mike amazon here author of
design and build great web apis due to a
scheduling conflict i'm not going to be
able to join you live today so i
pre-taped my talk testing your apis with
postman and newman if you're involved in
any aspect of the api
design program build release maintain
api testing is a critical element and
hopefully this talk will give you some
ideas on how you can improve and expand
your api testing program with these
tools i'm sorry i can't be there i hope
i get to see you sometime soon online or
maybe even in real life someday at some
conference near you thanks again and i
hope you enjoy this presentation
hi this is mike anderson and i'm here to
talk to you about testing your apis with
postman and newman testing is an
important part of the api stack so let's
focus on that for a little bit
first of all this is me this is how you
find me on linkedin and twitter and
github and youtube i have a youtube
channel so if you like what you're
seeing here there's more and all those
places i would love to connect with you
and find out what you're doing
the material i'm going to be talking
about today is from a book that i'm
completing called design and build great
web apis from pragmatic publishing so if
you like what you're seeing here you
want to check that out there'll be more
there
so here's what we're going to talk about
today we're going to talk about goals of
testing what is the idea behind testing
and why are we doing it we're going to
talk about things called srts simple
request test which is just a way to kind
of probe to make sure that things are
working fine we're going to talk about
testing with the postman ui and the chai
searching library i'll talk to you about
how i use that then i want to move to a
cli a command line interface proposal
called newman and show you how i wrap
that up to get my own ci cd service
cooking so that's what we're going to
focus on goals
srts postman
let's talk about the goals a little bit
goals are really important why are we
doing api tests it turns out that doing
tests for apis is not the same as
testing for code so it's really
important to keep this in mind
essentially what we're doing is we're
testing the interface that's all we can
test we can't really test the code
behind we don't know what services are
behind that api we just know how that
api behaves so it's important for us to
focus on the outside in kind of approach
and see what it is that we're actually
working on
second we want to at least validate
inputs and outputs is the url valid does
it actually respond to the method we're
using can we send the proper inputs and
get the proper output back that's really
that sort of first level probe kind of
testing it's not really detailed testing
but at least it gets us to the point
where we're getting started you can
think of this sort of as unit testing
for api's kind of approach
but what we really want to do is we want
to construct confirm the behavior of the
api we want to be confirmed confirm that
it actually does the things it's
supposed to do and that really comes up
in two areas so i call problem happy
path tests or the 200 tests if i send
this information in i should get a 200
okay in the filter back or if i try to
write a new record with the proper
inputs i should get a 200k okay and a
new record but i also need to test the
sand path or the ones where i expect to
get a 400 if i send an endowed filter
value or if i try to write a record
that's a duplicate or if i try to write
a record that's got improper inputs or
doesn't have the required fields i
should get that 400 bag so when i do my
tests i'm going to have both happy path
and sad path test that's really really
important
so let's see how we can put this
together
and let's focus on these ideas called uh
simple request tests or srts this is
sort of my minimal element i usually run
these srts while i'm actually doing the
build uh and before i've done an
extensive behavior test setup so srts
are a great way to just validate
endpoints sometimes i use srts on
somebody else's apis just but i can get
that started so i want to confirm the
url and confirm that it actually
responds and i want to validate that i
get 200 okay in the data i'm looking for
i don't always if especially if it's
somebody else's apis i'm not trying to
test this ad path so much as the happy
but if i'm doing it on my own apis which
i often do then i'll test that both i
said the happy path and the sad map i
use curl for this you can use curl or
wget or any other sort of simple http
library to get this job done and you'll
be fine really what you want to do is
collect up that output i usually write
it to a text file and i often check it
into the project it's part of my ci cd
level so as i'm writing code i run these
srts change the code run the srt and do
this over and over and over again and
really all i'm doing is eyeballing the
results at this point did i get a 200 do
i get a 400 that i get the fields i was
looking for when i want to write the
postman test the detailed test then i'll
actually do much more
check checking and questioning of the
shape and the actual values and the
response but here i just want to make
sure that it works out okay so
validating the input using curl or some
other tool and making sure that it
actually returns what it wants let's
take a look at an example of srt's in
action
okay so we want to test out this idea of
srts right so let me just show you what
i've got here in my project so i'm
actually in a node project right now
so this is my test space and you'll see
some reference here to postman and
newman we'll talk about those later
we're going to focus on this srt and srt
list
let me just give you a quick view of
what those srts look like
so this is my list of requests this
should look pretty familiar if you've
done uh
curl or wget or anything else like that
this is just a series this is my series
of happy
and sad path tests so i just write these
probes so in this example i'm trying to
see if there's actually i can create a
record this we should be invalid this
one will be okay this one would be a
duplicate so on and so forth so this is
really just my series of tests so let me
get out of here
clear this up and then we'll just do a
run i'll show you what this run looks
like and then i'll show you
uh
what the actual oh okay here we go
tests
there we go and then i'll show you what
the output looks like so the first thing
it does is it actually fires up my api
i'm running node so it fires it up
locally and then runs through all the
tests so you can actually see here i'm
going to go up to the to the early part
here
so you see all this output
so it starts with my simple happy path
elements lists and filters
and post and put and patch and delete
and then it starts my sad path elements
missing an email that one should work
this one is a duplicate
uh this one ignores the field this hat
size field's not valid in my schema
and then this one actually tries to get
a record that's not there and then
cleans up after it's done so it's a
pretty straightforward system now it's a
bit fiddly because i can't really read
that easily so one of the things i can
do is given like a list i can do
an output
file as well so now i'll just run the
same tests only this time it outputs the
main
responses to a file
so now i can take a look at that output
file so there's all that same
information that i had before but now
it's in a nice handy file that i can
check into ci cd
let me show you one other thing here
and that is the actual script itself
so
let's see here let's do this
color
scheme let's do it to uh
there we go it's a little bit easier to
read right
so what this does is remember uh it sets
up a
file starts my npm run so it assumes
that i've got npm running
and then goes through that file and then
reads every line as long as the line's
not a comment or a blank it actually
execute it whether or not it pipes it or
not based on a file that i supply so
it's a really simple script and it's
very very powerful and it gives us this
great way to do what we talked about
before this idea of srt testing
all right so let's go on to the next
step of actually using postman
okay so let's start looking at testing
with postman ui and the change is chai
gis assertion library
so postman is a fantastic
platform for apis in general it's
originally built in 2014 it's got design
build test all these other things inside
it uh now it does require a client-side
uh install you actually have a have to
have a client app running in order to do
that but it works out great and it's
easy to install on lots of different
platforms i've done it on lots of
machines and it's not a problem at all
now the way that the tool is built up is
it really has this pattern of
collections folders and requests
requests are the actual url and method
uh and arguments that you're going to
pass back and forth folders are a
collection of those requests and
collections are a bunch of folders so
you actually can build up this hierarchy
i usually uh arrange all my happy path
and all my sample different folders and
i keep my apis like my company api my
personal api my routing api so and so
forth in a collection uh sometimes i do
the collection slightly different if i
have different targets so if i have a
remote target or a local but i usually
handle that in a thing called
environment variables so there are
variable sets that i can i can create i
can create a stand-in for the server
address for example so environment
variables work at the global level and
at the collection level so you have this
this ability to kind of uh
adjust your target audience and still
keep the same tests which i really like
another thing i really like about
postman in general is they have a lot of
built-in scripts so if you're used to
doing things like like assertion
libraries and schema validation and
javascript well those libraries are
probably already in postman so you can
keep using them if you write a lot of
node code and you want to do things like
requests and so on so forth those are in
there as well there's more than a dozen
client libraries more than 10
node libraries it's a really really rich
environment for doing programming which
i think is very very important
now i use the library called uh chai js
which is an assertion library
and it's really just a way of actually
running tests uh it's very bdd style so
it's very outside in very damn north-ish
kind of kind of thing it has a very
fluent interface so it actually looks
almost like i would speak uh i expect
this object to include this string and i
actually can write it out that way so i
really like that as well it's a little
easier to share libraries for that
reason share that with other people who
are not necessarily
big type programming
i use the expect collection there's also
a should collection and a standard
assertion it's really just your style as
to what you would like but i'll show you
the expect version when they do it so
let's go ahead and build a couple of
tests and i'll show you how this works
i'll show you how the ui works and how
you can build up incap test results
all right so let's talk about just using
postman ui to do my testing so uh what
postman runs on as i said before is this
idea of collections and requests and so
what i'm going to do is add a new
request it's pretty easy i go to my
collection
i just want to say i want to add a new
test and then add it to the collection
and it puts it right in the group and
then i can start building and all i
really need to do to build is actually
just add a url to start and just test
that out so i actually have one here
where i added the url that's all it's
added
so it's just simply a probe to the root
of
an api
so we can see that we get our results
back
now we know this works now i can start
writing tests so i can actually just
write a series of tests by opening up
this test window here and editing the
test so what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to go back to when i've
already prepared for you so you don't
need to see me type
so this is how i write my tests these
tests actually come in groups i test
protocol details structure details and
value details and we'll talk about each
of those
so here's my postman test test really is
a two-step process i give a string and
then a function so i want to test if the
return is 200 and then i write a
function to do that and i can use that
chi js library to do expect so it's
postman.expect
the response code to equal 200. nice
fluent language i like that a lot
now i also want to test the header make
sure i'm getting application json back
so i pull the header a response header
and then i expect that header to include
the string application json now notice
i'm saying include and not equals there
might be some additional information in
that string but as long as that
content type header says application
json in it i know i'm going to be good
so that's protocol level but then i also
want to test the structure of the
response i get back so i grab the
response body which should be jason and
then i make sure it actually contains a
valid home object this this home
route should have this home object the
object should be an array
and then it should be that array of uh
anonymous objects that contain
id name rel and href each so these are
my link objects so you can say i wrote a
script here that said i expect the body
home to be an array and then for each of
the elements of that array then i expect
the item to have the property id
property name property rel property a
trap this is how i test the structure of
my api
then finally i want to test the values
so i know there's supposed to be at
least one item in that collection called
list so let me go get that item find the
one where the id equals list
then if assuming i get that i can test
other expectations like that item
shouldn't the id should be including
list the home name should include
company and the rel should include both
the words company and collection so i'm
testing the value as well so protocol
structure value is a key way to organize
your tests
so if i just run this right now and
see what results i get back hopefully
they should all pass so let's go take a
look and see what my results look like
and sure enough they all pass 200
content type it's a valid home object
and it's set to list company and
collection very cool now that's my happy
path right i can also do sad path
testing as well with the with the
postman library so let's take a look at
what sad pat testing looks like
right now i'm going to try to create a
record that doesn't have the required
fields
so i should get a status a protocol
status of 400 and i should get a problem
json message back not just application
json but one specifically structured to
tell me what the problem was and this is
an rfc type so you can look up if you
look up problem json you'll find it in
the rfc so i get the response i get the
body and now i'm taking a look is it a
valid error object with all the right
properties that i expect
and if it is can i actually find the
values that it should have the error
type the error status and the error
details should say missing company and
so on and so forth so this is how i can
test for my sad path so again let's do
the same thing let's take a run at this
and see what the results are
and sure enough i pass all my tests so
it's a 400 i got the problem jason back
it's a valid error object that includes
error 400 and missing company name and
status so that's how i can do ui
testing with postman ui and i can also
run these as a collection as well so if
i go back over here
and i just uh
click on this and say run it's going to
bring up a test runner for me so it can
run the whole collection so i can build
up a whole series of tests test for
various responses test for various items
objects urls and then i just press run
company and i'm going to get all the
results back from all those elements and
if i'm lucky i get all passing tests
all right so that's how i'm going to do
that with postman
let's move on now to talk about how we
can do this at a command line level and
not just at the ui level
all right so finally how do we start to
automate this whole process i love the
postman ui but i have a lot of ci cd
pipeline or build tools or processes or
scripting that i need to do and that's
where this idea of a command line
interface comes in handy in a tool
called new
so you can automate your testing this
way you can automate your testing with
newman cli it's built around 2016 it's
really simple it's an npm package so
it's simple to install just install i
install it globally install slash g
newman and then i also need to install
this other piece
that we'll talk about a little bit later
but once you install it it's newman run
and the name of the collection i'll show
you how to get the name of the
collection and how you can take a look
at that as well it's just really an id
number and it's a basically a fantastic
way to put things together
so i can actually use the newman the
postman api to pull collection uh test
collections and environment variables
down to my own machine there's a great
api and now i'll need an api key but
it's pretty simple and then i just use
curl with that
api key and i can do lots of things like
manage my collections uh pull them down
store them locally and stuff like that
so newman utility actually plus the api
lets me automate this entire process i
can pull the proper collection and the
proper environment and then i can run
the tool and then i can actually
generate a really cool report
and put it all together in a single
script so i have this thing called test
run which i'll show you here in just a
bit that lets me do all that information
pull it together run the tests and then
i'll be all set
now the tests are simple text output so
it's not it's not great but it's very
effective it's very very good but if you
want something really more special
there's a great add-on tool called a
reporter tool so the whole newman family
has these reporter tools and there's one
called html extra which i like really
really well so pull that down with the
npm and then you just need to add that
dash
r for report dash r in the name of html
extra and you'll get a great output
report which we'll take a look at as
well so automation is pretty simple get
the newman client use the api to pull
the collections and environments you
need
run that and if you want to have this
extra html report so let's actually take
a look and see how that would look in
command line exactly all right so let's
see how this all works and a command
line type experience
so for starters
let's just uh do this here
this is our postman section right so
i've got a little run script
got a little configuration file and then
i've got this environment variable which
actually holds my api key so we're not
going to worry too much about that
basically what i want to do is i
actually want to run that same series of
tests that i was running before in the
ui but i want to do it at the command
line level and i can do that with a cool
tool
tool called newman
so newman is pretty handy so what i'm
actually going to do here is just show
you
what i've what i've got built here i'm
just going to show you and we'll do the
same thing color scheme
so
all i really need to do is have this
utility called newman installed along
with this html reporter we'll look at it
a second and a little bit of curl
because i'll use curl to actually do the
api work
so i run i check out my config make sure
everything is there and once that's done
i take this first step so this step
right here is where i actually call the
api to pull in the collection
and the environment that i need from
postman so i'm actually calling up to
postman server
pulling that information down these are
two json files
pulling that information down and
storing them on my local drive
then once i do that then i can run the
test so this is it newman run the
collection and the environment and
whether or not i'm doing outputs this
bail gives me some
feedback information on scripting so i
can get exit codes one or zero
so i can either run it straight or i can
actually do a pipe
so it's pretty simple
all i really need to do is run this
routine check to see if tests pass or
fail this will come in handy because i
can actually use this as part of a ci cd
experience so use the api to pull the
collection and the environment variables
i need and then use the newman utility
to actually use that data to actually
run the tests pretty straightforward so
i'll show you how what that looks like
right here
so now what i'm going to do is
do the test run and i'm going to aim it
at a local server i can name it a local
remote server but i'm just going to aim
it at a local server here we're just
going to run this test and it's actually
going to run through all those tests and
then save them to disk so it actually
saves them to an output file for me so
this is my output
so remember we've got happy path and sad
path tests right so here's my set of
happy path test i do a get
list filter all those other things
and i also do my sad path testing too
right so i can read something that's not
there check to see if something has a
missing email and i get all of that
information for me that's what i want
and then what happens is i get a nice
report at the end that's spooled out to
disk how many requests how many scripts
how many pre-requests because that's
where my libraries are and then the
total number of assertions so i actually
just write this out to the file and then
i can use this in the future
so that's essentially uh the work that i
do now let me just show you what the uh
configuration looks like just you get an
idea behind it so it's pretty simple
it's pretty straightforward
um i've got a title and then this is the
collection id and the environment ids
that i have i don't have a remote setup
for this particular set of tests but i
could use them if i want and then i can
say this is how you write them out you
can write up the environment the
collection and the output set so now
what i've done is i've gone through all
this experience building the postman ui
tests i can then pull them and add them
into my ci cd collections so this
becomes the way that i actually can run
a full-on test
deploy and then re-test remotely every
single time
okay
so we've taken a look at a couple of
different things
first of all we talked about the idea of
the goals of testing you're really
working on an outside-in approach i
can't
really concern myself with the code
behind the api i need to focus on the
api and focus on its behavior how is it
behaving what does it allow me to do
what does it prevent me from doing and i
want to focus on that happy and sad path
version of testing right i need to test
for 400 in the right place as well as
test for 200 in the right place
so i talked about these srts and the
value of just like poking the end points
focus on the url and the method and
check out the body it's just a curl or a
w get kind of tool to do it
and i just want to make sure that
everything is working properly it's not
really testing yet
but it's enough for me while i'm
building to get something super quick
and get some great feedback
now once it's time to really build up my
test libraries then i want to use
postman and i use the chai js library so
i want to create a collection i want to
create file folders and requests i can
use that assertion for that bdd style
expect outside in kind of approach and i
can build up a set of reliable test
modules and share those across using
environment variables and things like
that and be sure again make sure you're
doing both happy and sad testing as
you're doing this and finally once i
know i've got my apis tested well and
running in the post
ui i can actually use the newman command
line interface to start automating my
test press processing as well so i can
install newman i can run this little
tool called test run which i'll share
with you here at the end and then i can
actually even add a custom html report
if i want to this html reporter tool so
now this becomes part of my pipeline
series i can actually build test and if
it passes deploy and it passes test
remotely to make sure that that worked
as well all through this process with
test with a post
so that's really all there is really to
it goals srts postman ui automating with
the client so lots of resources i talked
about in here so i'll make sure i share
all of those with you uh you'll get
these slides you can check this out um
you can find out more about this whole
testing process and lots of other api
stuff in the book talked about srts
where you can get postman and all these
other things so all these utilities
everything that i showed you will be
downloadable as well so hopefully that's
helped
add to the stack remember testing is a
key part of everything so test your your
apis with postman and newman and i hope
to talk to you again soon bye